Step five in the object or in analysis process has to do with relationships.
The main elements in the class model diagram are going to correspond classes and
relationships. And we're going to depict the classes ash compartmentized,
rectangles and relationships are going to be indicated by
lines connecting the rectangles. And there are going to be three different
kinds of relationships that we'll look at. One kind is generalization, and
that's indicated by a line at, and at one end of the line will be a little
open triangle. The second kind is called aggregation.
This is going to be used for situations like what we mentioned parts of, and
in this case, the line ends with an open diamond, and then if we don't
have any adornment on the line at all, that's going to be a general association.
So let's look at each of those three categories of relationships and
see if we can find examples of them in our, our example problem.